hey guys you can find us on patreon now
patreon.com
crystalia every week there's gonna be
free episodes of congratulations on
youtube and wherever you get your audio
but if you sign up for six dollars on
our patreon
you get extended episodes you get the
extended episodes of congratulations
every week and you also get a bonus
episode a month i'm a hooker now
okay if you want to support the show if
you're a long time listener
and you're like how can i support the
show though here's your ticket dude
here's your ticket i'll be doing bonus
content over there
also if you sign up for the top tier
you're
on fire now basically you are a producer
of the show i'm gonna do monthly
amas where you guys can pitch me ideas
for the show
and you'll also be able to see yourself
in the credits because you're a producer
of congratulations
i'll tell you what the top tier entry to
the log cabin that's what that is
go on over to patreon.comcrystalia and
check it out
and uh we'll see you there man hello
everyone and
welcome to congratulations it's episode
[Music]
crazy
i you know it's another episode and i
wasn't sure
man i you know i can do the episode
really whenever i want and i don't
really
have too much going on right now so i
decided to do it
on uh this certain day that i'm doing it
now which
i don't need to tell you guys because
you're listening to it whenever it's
you're listening to it
and um so i just i was like i'll do that
and i set up and i told the producers
and i was like let's do this [ __ ]
and then all day i i just didn't i was
trying to get into the mood
and i was just not sure and i you know
you podcast mode is like it's like
[ __ ]
you know it's like it's like album it's
like when an artist is an al
it's like when a rapper is in album mode
you don't want to [ __ ] with him
you don't want to diss a rapper when
he's in album mode
do you know what i'm talking about
because if you disa rapper when he's in
album
mode then he's at the top of his game
and he's ready and he could rhyme a lot
of things really quickly at you
and you're [ __ ] honestly you know what
i'm talking about you're [ __ ]
you know you're you're if
if i dis a rapper and he's in album mode
say i'm a rapper and i diss another
rapper and i'm not in album mode
and that rapper is in album mode then
that guy's just gonna be like hold up
hold up a second cars bars
and i'm [ __ ] didn't i mean he'd be
like hold on
hold on a second math bath
and i'm [ __ ] you know what i mean
because i'm like wait what rhymes
you understand what i'm saying so
podcast mode is the equivalent of album
mode and i was trying to get into
podcast mode
and i couldn't get into podcast mode and
guess what i'm not in podcast
mode but i don't want to fail you guys
so let's see if we can kind of swoop
into podcast mode
let's see if we can kind of just catch
podcast mode
catch in podcast mode that's what i'm
trying to do that's what i'm trying
today
um but [ __ ] it dude we're all in
do you know as a performer or whatever
the [ __ ] you know sometimes you gotta go
on stage
and you and you don't and you don't know
you don't feel it you're arguing with
your you know your wife or you're
[ __ ]
mad at your your agents or whatever the
[ __ ] and you're like well they said that
or you're talking to the guy off stage
who's set up the whole [ __ ] show and
you're like
why are these people all drunk up front
and he's like i gotta go hey and
everybody let go it's quickly and you
come out you're just like
hi everybody you know what i mean and
like you're you're but you're in your
head and in your heart you're just
[ __ ]
deeply mad you know but you're and
you're just like so what's going on out
there [ __ ]
ottawa or whatever the [ __ ]
and you gotta do that [ __ ] but um yeah i
don't really know you
but but but you gotta so you gotta
swallow it and [ __ ] just do your [ __ ]
and so that's what that's what that's
what we do baby that's what we [ __ ]
do
so i'm i'm so
i'm i'm doing that and you know it's
honestly uh
it's fine you know it's fine it's fine
we went to [ __ ] um
the supermarket uh today with
my boy with my son and he [ __ ] that
kid is me dude he was sitting in the
[ __ ]
uh you know the shopping cart that you
push
bro we would look like [ __ ] to get
the lacroix and we would
we would go grab the lacroix and bring
it back by the time we brought it back
he would be like
the other way and his leg up chilling
like he like he had a [ __ ] robe on
just like
oh hello mommy and daddy and and dude it
was so
[ __ ] hit oh dude we took them we were
walking down the street we took them
into this toy shop which is just
straight out of [ __ ] 1950s like i
didn't even know there were
like like toy shops you think they have
like video games and [ __ ]
bro i'm a new dad i had no [ __ ] idea
i haven't been to a toy shop but they
have like legit like trinkets
and it's like yeah but is this
pleasantville i don't understand
a toy shop that has like a thing that
you wind up you know what i'm talking
about it's 2021.
kids are out there literally shooting
each other in the [ __ ] face
with uh with uh uh call of duty
and this these these things have like tr
trinkets that you wind up and a monkey
will just go ah
this toy shop had that [ __ ] and calvin
was just like
looking at all of the toys and he picked
up this bell this [ __ ] rotten eight
dollar bell and it was just going ding
ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding through the whole toy the
whole shop and the guy's just like ah ah
he actually [ __ ] said uh just so you
guys know i have to leave in a little
bit so if if you want something just
maybe just
you know figure it out dude and i'm like
this [ __ ]
i looked at my clock it was 5 37 like
when do you close dude
if it's six we got time he just didn't
want [ __ ] cali to be with the bell
dude he was holding it upside down like
a [ __ ] like a disrespectful
uh a dis a disrespectful [ __ ]
just
you would hand it to him [ __ ] down to
where you know
you do it like if he was the salvation
army [ __ ] santa like doing it like
that
you'd give it to him like that and he
would just look at you and he would go
and flip it over and go
like a [ __ ] disrespectful 13 month
old
and it was cute dude but he did that and
then we bought the [ __ ] bell and then
we walked down the street and he's just
kinky
like a small [ __ ] bald salvation army
santa
and he's just kink kinking and then we
went into the grocery store and he's
just
kinky kinking and we look around we we
look to go get the lacroix
and then we look back and he's just
[ __ ] sprawled out
like he's the [ __ ] uh who's that
the guy who says champagne on the old
snl spit skits
spits or skits ah skits yeah that's
right
yes we [ __ ] up already dude my [ __ ]
is my [ __ ] are my lipstick yes do i
have [ __ ]
two injuries in my back yes high and low
yes dude high and low dude l1 and
probably l40
ah yes i can't [ __ ] wait to wake up
tomorrow and be like
oh cause every morning i wake up i go ah
yes dude it sucks man my lips are just
[ __ ]
and my back is always think of that jay
to kiss song
a workout i keep my back all nice
not descriptive enough
[Laughter]
i work out i keep my back all nice
children's book um
number one dad how many [ __ ] dads
have a number one dad thing you know
you're not the [ __ ] world we all tied
we're all tied as the number one dad
dude i'm not i'm i'm a good
i'm a [ __ ] i love that boy man
i [ __ ] you know you know what i
realized is i don't [ __ ] really look
people in the eyes all that much like
people come over and [ __ ] not so much
lately because it's the covet and
[ __ ]
everybody hates me and but but when
people come over and and when they come
over i realize they'll be over for like
two and a half hours and i [ __ ]
haven't even looked in their eyes dude
and i'm serious and i'm like they're
gonna think i [ __ ] don't like them
and it's not that i don't like them it's
just that i'm [ __ ] insecure i used to
think like
i used to think as a kid like if you
make eye contact with somebody for too
long like they would steal your soul
because my whole family was indian and
um no but i i really did i used to think
that [ __ ]
and i was like you can't look at
somebody for too long and then somebody
when i was like in my early 20s was like
hey [ __ ] they said to my friend you
know chris doesn't [ __ ] like look at
us
when he when when he had
and i was like oh [ __ ] they're catching
on so i try i try to fix it and i
[ __ ] don't fix it and
now it's just like a part of my life and
i don't [ __ ] i don't really look at
people in the eyes
but the one person i look in in their
eyes
[ __ ] for a long time is calvin and i
don't even realize it
because like he could have my soul i
don't give a [ __ ] um
anyway god i'm so [ __ ] i'm so [ __ ]
up with the [ __ ] that i think
ah wow
um anyway wow we went to uh
joshua tree uh this past week
uh wifey was like
let's just get out let's let's
let's go you know she wanted
just let's go let's [ __ ] let's just
pick up
and leave i was like what where are we
gonna go it's [ __ ]
half the world thinks that you're gonna
die if they cough on you and like
you know the other half is mad
and she's like let's just rent a place
in joshua tree and i'm like what's
and i'm like first of all dude i'm like
hold up what's joshua tree
because i know i've been in la for
[ __ ] 28 years
and i've heard this joshua tree [ __ ]
i've heard about joshua tree
now i i want to tell you right off the
bat
i don't like the name joshua tree
okay because it's a place
it's not a tree and the name joshua
[ __ ] sucks okay and and you know that
and even joshua's are listening right
now and they're like
well he does raise a point dude the name
joshua
first of all the name josh isn't great
okay
but it's way better and if you're a
[ __ ] cop
if you're josh and you're like well but
it's joshua
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about you're the guy who holds
the [ __ ] wine like this
where you're like just hold it like that
[ __ ] and uh
like you're much closer to where the
[ __ ] ascot than any any other
[ __ ]
and um
uh [ __ ] dude one time we were doing an
acting exercise in high school
and my buddy jason he he we pushed him
into a closet
and it was on stage and he [ __ ] came
out of the closet with a [ __ ] pink
boa on and he
and and i cried laughing and that story
has [ __ ] nothing to do
with any of this but i don't give a [ __ ]
dude what's it matter i'm unraveling and
so uh
so so [ __ ] we were in joshua tree
and the [ __ ] we brought callie and we
and we brought two friends
didn't even look at them in their eyes
the whole [ __ ] time but
but calvin we we picked up when
we left we went to joshua tree and i was
like why the [ __ ] is it called joshua
tree
and it's because it's at the elevation
where the
the the the these certain trees
grow only in the this elevation of where
joshua tree is
and these trees look like [ __ ]
they don't look good and people are
always like oh how cool that the trees
only grow in this elevation
and you can't get them at other
elevations and it's like yeah but the
trees [ __ ]
suck you know what i'm talking about
they don't look like nice spruce trees
or like christmas trees
they're all they look like [ __ ]
do you know what they look like the they
uh
like [ __ ] up like um
marionettes is what they look like like
the [ __ ] when
in sync did the bye bye bye video or if
it was backstreet boys i don't know who
it is
but um and they are all like got like
[ __ ] coming out of it like they look
like maybe they're like cactuses or
something or cacti
cactuses i don't want to say cacti and
so um
but they're ugly ass [ __ ] trees and
the reason why they're called joshua
trees is because the mormon joshua was
like the one who discovered it or
something
okay so the place is called joshua tree
and everybody goes and if you go you
it's like 85 to 90
chance you'll take mushrooms
and the and and uh yeah
and so and one of the and we went there
we played games
and we didn't really have a [ __ ] room
to put calvin in there were five
bedrooms but two of them were
over in another [ __ ] place outside of
the house
it was like a casitas that they called
it or some [ __ ] to make it sound nice
and we're like we're not gonna put
[ __ ] calvin alone in a casitas like
he's some [ __ ] pimp
and so we put him in they had a big
closet and we just [ __ ]
he slept in the big-ass closet
and like we had his [ __ ] nan it all
hunched over watching him sleep in his
big-ass closet with the air purifier and
the [ __ ]
sound thing to there were so many
gadgets in there he
he was he he was like the guy in the
movie of the
enemy of the state with will smith
that's like on the computer with all the
[ __ ] gadgets and [ __ ] just
that's the guy that's just like i'm way
ahead of you that's who my
my son was at joshua tree
and we were with people and and some of
the people did mushrooms
and and it was so funny because we
couldn't like
we were like you're not you're not you
it doesn't seem like you're on mushrooms
and
and one of the guys was like yeah no
it's not affecting me
oh [ __ ] he goes
he says yeah it's not really affecting
me it's not really affecting me and he
he says it's not really affecting me and
looks at his hand and says oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] sew on mushrooms honestly it's not
affecting me what the [ __ ]
how many fingers is that
yeah it's not really affecting me did
you guys put this planter's peanut guy
on my hand
trippy man the [ __ ] he's got no [ __ ]
um does the players peanut guy wear
[ __ ] pants that's [ __ ] dude
come on get with it companies get with
the times dude
you gotta [ __ ] put pants on the
planter's peanut guy put pants on the
planets being the sanic
um and he [ __ ] stays drinking lacroix
even at night dude
i'm disrespecting uh
dude my son does the highest burps
it's crazy dude it's like the [ __ ]
it's like the michael jackson of burping
he just goes he'll just be chilling i'll
go
um it's cute as [ __ ] though man
um yeah so we went to joshua tree it was
cool some of us did mushrooms not me
and then uh we went to walk around and
it was too windy and we came back oh and
we went to a [ __ ] place
where it was like dude it's like it's
one of those places where like the charm
the charm though if you're talking about
the charm of a place the place [ __ ]
sucks you know
have the place be all nice if it's
charming it's just
dirty and a lot of brown is around
uh so we went in and we were like
it's one of the we went into one of
these stores and it had like everything
that
the person collected within the past 100
years you know one of those stores
where they're just like ah that let me
tell you about and you're just like
no you're just like let me get the thing
with the three bears on it because it's
[ __ ] it's cute because there's a
little bear and the two
and the couple bearing it's like gonna
be me and kristen and then the calvin is
the little bear
ah well let me tell you you know the
first the the i i originally when i
first got here it wasn't because it was
because i was
i was going to get a surgery but what
happened was instead of the
instead of that i came here and i got a
deep healing and a healing and a
[ __ ] healing the so much healing is
going on in [ __ ] joshua tree
that it's like you'd think there'd be
no disease and
and and the more a person talks about
healing the more they wear
[ __ ] maroon and brown and [ __ ] and
like tan
and like aquamarine you know i'm talking
about and she was just like the healing
and the healing and i found my husband
and the healing
and the healing i found my husband and
then so the three bears in the
and i'm just sitting there dude with my
[ __ ] mask on
and and kristen's got her mask on and
the only people with no masks is calvin
and the [ __ ] lady that's talking
about healing
and i'm like this [ __ ] chick better
not have covet dude healing and the
healing and the as she's saying the
ancient healing
healing and the healing in the [ __ ]
like the old cartoons with the [ __ ]
smoke
we would go in front like the steak
would be smelling up to
up to daffy duck and it would just like
lure him in and daffy would be like
and then healing and the healing and
that's the covert to my son
and my son just is like
we better stay here so he [ __ ] gets
some healing but like and she
and and and kristen is so nice dude
she's just like the nicest person and
now like i got to be nice because
god forbid i'm not nice and somebody
catches it and [ __ ] puts it on the
on the internet say the [ __ ] nara dude
oh and he's a dick and uh
and uh oh she was talking about healing
and the [ __ ] love of her life and how
she got a three
a a [ __ ] statue of three bronze bears
and he's
and he rolled his eyes really and he
rolled his eyes
really i don't think so
and so uh
so kristen is so nice to it and she's
just like really isn't that
really isn't that interesting really i'm
so glad we just picked up and just came
to joshua tree
really oh wow yeah see so that's funny
because and she's just making [ __ ] up
that isn't even
but because you know his parents
they were both they met at war so we get
it
she's just making [ __ ] up so the lady
feels comfortable
and so i [ __ ] so we got the bronze
bears and [ __ ] and we put it in our
in our [ __ ] office and now it's there
and now we have that thing so now we
have that thing
so so it's good you know
things things man
i used to collect so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
when i was a kid
so much [ __ ] mcdonald's fry holders
like for real pins of movies i went to
like
they used to hand out pins i used to
collect pogs i used to keep
all the [ __ ] man and one day i was like
this is gonna be a
big problem i better throw it all the
way now and i threw it
all away i threw everything away
everything away
and it felt good it felt cleansing and
that was the day
that i made sure i wasn't going to
become a hoarder because dude let me
tell you if i didn't do that
i would have been a hoarder you watched
i show hoarders
some people hoard their own [ __ ] and
this is true i saw an episode where a
guy's like
well yeah this is all my stuff okay cool
see ya and they were like well what's up
back in the [ __ ]
thing it wasn't a casitas but it was
like a [ __ ] uh uh
another place that he built he was like
oh that yeah oh yeah
okay we go in there i guess that he just
kept his [ __ ]
in paint buckets uh
they opened it up they're like what's it
oh oh oh
you know when you get like
they were like hurt to their core oh
like
you ever get [ __ ] really hurt and
like like [ __ ]
my son i was eating [ __ ] ahi tuna
and i was she and krista was like watch
him for a sec while i blow my hair
and she was she was blowing her and i
was eating the hot
the ahi steak from a good restaurant and
[ __ ] eating it
and i and he was just he's always trying
to grab whatever the [ __ ] is around it
doesn't matter
and he's trying to grab it and he goes
to grab my fork i'm like buddy this is a
fork it's sharp
and i had the nice knife to [ __ ] cut
the ahi tuna
and he went to go grab something like my
[ __ ]
my pills so i don't kill myself or some
[ __ ] and he grabbed the [ __ ] pills
and uh and and i was like buddy and i
took the pills back and i put it on my
dresser on my night table and as i did
that he grabbed the sharp knife
and just real quickly like a [ __ ]
like just jab like stabbed me in the
[ __ ] hand like
like grabbed it and he goes uh like
like yeah what i'm gonna cut you up real
nice like that's what it looked like
like a [ __ ] hat catch up real nice
hey you guys i got something sharp here
i'll carve you out something nice
like that's how he and i and i looked at
him and he
oh and it and i went oh like that like
that
like the real [ __ ] [ __ ] that you feel
when you get when you think there's
danger like that
you don't scream like whoops you you
know
you went oh like because it was like oh
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] stuck
i'm stuck in my hand and also my son
i'm looking at my son and he's i see all
his [ __ ] six teeth
he's smiling i'm like this
motherfucker's dexter
he looks at me he just goes this [ __ ]
guy stuck
me and he's laughing at his dad dude
and it was in that moment where i
realized dude like if my son
grew up and killed me i'd [ __ ] be
i'd i i'd [ __ ] be
i'd be worried that he was gonna get
caught dude and i almost cried when i
said it
oh i almost cried when i said it okay
that's all that's all good dude but when
you're a dad
emotion comes [ __ ] it's right at your
face dude
it's right at your [ __ ] face man you
know how emotions like in your belly
sometimes and you're like huh
i [ __ ] caught me off guard here it
comes it's rising but then the emotion
as a man
it gets to your throat sometimes and
then it's like i'm just teasing you dude
i'm just teasing you i'll go back down
to your tummy
and i'll [ __ ] and we'll just we'll
chill a little bit
and maybe at a wedding we might rise
back up or a funeral we might rise up
sometimes we get here dude
sometimes you get here sometimes when
the emotion gets right in your [ __ ]
like that old commercial like that old
[ __ ] what was that sizzle commercial
it gets you here it gets you right here
dude there used to be a [ __ ]
commercial for like sizzler
or like steak sauce a1 steak sauce was
what it was
and he would go and and in the
commercial they would cut to a guy and
he said it gets you here it gets you
right here
that's where the [ __ ] emotion goes it
gets you here it gets you right here
as a man but when you're a father and a
new father at that
the emotion says [ __ ] it and there it's
right behind your face dude
it's right behind your face so you do
[ __ ] like you almost cry
when your son grabs the bell and you're
like oh this is the first [ __ ] toy
i'm gonna buy him this is the first toy
that he picked out at this [ __ ]
classic toy shop
and he's just upside down dinging it and
i'm paying for it
and the guy's like can i get can i get
get your card
and i and i go to pay for it and i
[ __ ]
and i feel the emotion break through
right at my eyes
because of i'm a new dad and because all
of the [ __ ] that i'm going through also
though
and uh and i'm thinking this is the
first thing i'm buying my son
and i'm [ __ ] getting emotional right
now talking about it but it's not
quite at my face it gets you here it
gets you right here at this moment so
i'm all good baby
i'm all good but yeah man um
and i know what you guys want me to talk
about i know what you guys want me to
talk about because it was a [ __ ]
you talked about you know i talked about
it last time the [ __ ]
i can update you guys about the about
the depends thing
depends part two a lot of you guys were
really asking me in my [ __ ]
in my dms and [ __ ]
uh about how cause i commented on the
depends
social media uh
i think i did the this emoji or
something or fire emoji or something
and uh
a lot of you know first of all why the
[ __ ] does depends have a social media
presence
who's following adult diapers okay
that's very weird that's very weird that
depends has
a thousand three hundred and three
followers on instagram on instagram
it's not even just like on twitter i
would get it because it's like if you
need depends
and you wanna deal at least tweet like
hey you can get the pens 20
off [ __ ] here but who the [ __ ] wants
to see pictures of adult diapers
like what kind of weird [ __ ] so
but they have a hundred a thousand three
hundred followers on instagram
and now your boy's one of them because
i'm involved with them
because i wear them at night and i did
it
i did it a few nights
now i last time i told you i win against
my body
because i was going to wear the depends
and i didn't want to have to get up to
piss
at night but instead i
because of that since you can't stop the
pee you know there's no cork that you
can put in the tip of your penis
so i got the depends and i put the
depends on and i'm like i win body i
ain't getting up for you
i trumped my body right so i did it a
few nights
and every night i pissed all over the
bed
okay every night
and that's three of them there was piss
all over my sheets
okay not a little
if you were a guy and you were going to
be like well chris did the diaper get
most of it
i'd have to be like well half and half
i don't piss a little either i piss a
lot like kristen will go tt she'll be
like i gotta go
and already she's back i'm like what
when i go piss it's as long as some
people shits
like for real i'm not [ __ ] around
dude i go piss
for a long time and i was like depends
let's see what you got guess what you
got not much
i did it once when i was 30 and the [ __ ]
was awesome
i don't know what the [ __ ] dude by the
way
i was talking i was telling this to my
therapist i don't you know
and she was like well dude you uh
it's gonna be really hard to pee in bed
and i was like why and she's like well
because you don't
you don't do that ever and it's going to
be like a mind [ __ ] and i was like
we'll see dude i'm in control of my own
body
and i've done it before when i was 30.
and i did it
and it was so hard to piss laying down
you ever try piss laying down
um but i got you have to calm yourself
and you have to you have to relax
and krista was right there too she was
like are you
you know wait i actually don't even
remember you
i was i cause i think we were both woken
up at the same
time and i did it and i [ __ ]
i just there was so much piss on the bed
anyway uh it's so i don't give a [ __ ]
dude you can't wear them to bed maybe
you could wear them out if you have a
little bit of a leak
but anyway it depends i know i was like
oh i want you to sponsor me
this is probably not a good [ __ ]
sponsor at this point now
so yeah i pissed all over the place and
it gets
so heavy dude the diaper the diaper gets
so heavy you could curl it and like work
out
[Music]
um
this is my life now you know
we boarded my dogs because they were um
we didn't come to joshua tree
and they all came back with [ __ ]
kennel cough so that's cool
four dogs are just they're all [ __ ]
walking around like smokers
just i swear to god one of them coughs
with their [ __ ] tongue out like
they're the mask
it's so it's like he's
you leave me in there i'll [ __ ] come
dude one of them the trash dog
chenzo he he [ __ ] spits up dude i
swear to god
dogs don't have lips but i saw him go
like this once
he just goes
it's like he's [ __ ] jim carrey he's
like a four-legged gym carry
it's so and i'm just like all right dude
i get it
and he [ __ ] spits up and then my son
crawls on it and i gotta google can kids
get
[ __ ] kennel cough and it's always
it's never no
you know what i'm talking about even
though even though you know
kids can't get kennel cough because
that's why it's called kennel cough
otherwise it would just be called
bronchitis
but it's never no you talk to any doctor
well can i get this from that well it's
not like you know
well then what the [ __ ] is this world
you know
just say no if the chance is [ __ ] .02
just say [ __ ] no dude you google it
and it's like
in a very rare situation
sometimes in africa it's been known that
a four-month-old
has gotten kendall call and it's like
dude is my [ __ ] son
who lives in l.a gonna get kennel cough
from a [ __ ]
boarded up dog that was in west
hollywood
no but now cause it says
well you can't no definitive proof and i
now i got to worry because my son's
crawling all over my [ __ ] trash dog
spit
um so they all got kennel cough and
they're all just [ __ ] coughing
all over the place dude
and even beforehand they were like do
they have their shots and we were like
yeah and like good because kennel
cough's going around but should be okay
they all came back in the [ __ ] car
coughing all over the [ __ ] place
anyway i think one of them's better now
but
the other the other two whatever
it doesn't matter one came back with an
eye infection and [ __ ]
gotta we had to give him a [ __ ] eye
patch like a pirate
so this is my life now
now i got kennel cough dude i just
looked at my i was looking at my
camera roll today i got [ __ ]
uh 30 000
videos of my like my son it's
unbelievable
and in i would say 35
to 40 of them
you know i take a lot with his
grandparents my parents
my mom is in the background just my
my son is doing the most adorable [ __ ]
he'll be like saying
tata for the first time i'm waving
and i'm like ah and in the background my
mom is like
what's the what is the what's the
cadillac what's the four-door cadillac
and you're just like do you do you
understand
mike i'm do i need a six-letter word for
a four-door cadillac and i'm just like
you great you ruined it
and then i'm like ma and that's how
every video ends
my son does the most adorable [ __ ] like
stands for the first time for 12 seconds
and my mom's in the back she's either
you know i don't know she
i don't know if she she's either white
or jewish and i'm just like well for
[ __ ] sake dude
ma
that's how every video is
my son figured out how to put you know
this
the square in the square and the
triangle in the triangle he figures it
out for the first time i get a video of
him looking at the square
and putting it in the square and him
taking
the triangle and putting in the triangle
and i'm like he knows
shapes how beautiful and
as my son puts the triangle in the
triangle my mom's like well you know he
died of cancer
ma
if somebody has had cancer
in a 100 mile radius
my mom has told you
that's it my mom has told you that's
where the sentence ends
you know about it did you know that
because there's my mom if somebody
has had a freak accident within an
80 mile radius you know about it
because there's my mom
if someone has been married recently
in a 100 mile radius you know about it
because there's my mom
dude one time i swear to god my mom said
oh also
if you don't know the person you'll know
about it
because there's my mom my mom will be
like do you know lauren you went to
school with her at [ __ ] in
in no who's that lauren you know
i don't remember you know her sister
played volleyball
and and she was in your grade and then
lauren was three years younger
and then she starts to get mad and i'm
like oh yeah okay sure yeah
she uh she got married and her dad died
the next day that's what she [ __ ]
told me that's not a joke
dude she hit me with the [ __ ] one-two
punch [ __ ] wedding
death bam dude
i ca i can't imagine how wide my mom's
eyes went when [ __ ] four weddings in
the funeral came out when she heard that
that was gonna be a movie
my mom's straight you know there's a
movie with [ __ ] hugh grant and it's
gonna be called four weddings in a
funeral i think my mom literally goes
like this
and it had a [ __ ] cardiac arrest and
they needed it and she was like
uh if i her if i die make sure you tell
everyone within a hundred mile radius
dude that movie my mom was
first in line for four weddings in a
funeral no doubt
hugh grant said what sign me up
that's what she did
funerals and weddings dude what happened
wha
what is it about moms once a kid comes
out of you you just gotta tell everybody
about death and weddings
what is it it's like [ __ ] they just
go
my work here is done you know who died
[Music]
all done um so this is who's getting
married
just [ __ ] lists just [ __ ]
a scroll like the mask's tongue that's
two mask references in one podcast
for those of you who are listening to
this i just drank really [ __ ]
disrespectfully with my lacroix
my lacroix my lime lacroix what is it
how is it [ __ ] taste like lime if
nothing's in it dude
we're all dude i drink we're dying
there's no way you're drinking lacroix
not dying just so you know anyway
all good yeah so how many [ __ ]
how many commercials can shaq be in
like for real dude you know what i'm
talking about
how many [ __ ] commercial how could
you
look at when i by the way when i said
this
everybody listening or watching goes
like this oh yeah he has been in way too
many commercials
so how can you how can you
buy a product if shaq is hawking it
in the past four years how could you see
shaq holding a product and be like well
oh i gotta get that because he just
hawks
every product i looked it up
he's endorsed over 50 things currently
so how can you just be like oh well
i believe him
the guy's not [ __ ] the general motors
ben gay these are just
ones that come off the top of my head
general
general motors uh bengay uh [ __ ] icy
hot
does he do bengay and icy hot it's like
pick one dude
hi shaq uh buy the [ __ ] that's how it
should just be from now on
he buys [ __ ] then i would have respect
for it
like that [ __ ] petey pablo song where
he's like drink hanukking because
because i like it and they're paying me
for it
petey pablo you know the name petey
pablo
so [ __ ] awesome that song take my
shirt off swinging like a helicopter
when i first heard that song i thought
okay
got a new favorite song and it's been my
favorite song since
because i like how it's so so specific
and he's so passionate
about taking your shirt off and swinging
it around your head like helicopter
because if you're gonna do something you
better do it with all of you dude
you better do it with all of you and
this is something that i'm telling you
guys
because you're listening to this if you
do something give it your all
give it your all dude
you know i would go on stage i would
give it my all at this podcast
i give it my all it's not always good
but you give it your all dude you have
to
[ __ ] man and that is why life rips dude
that is why life rips because you can
give your all to something
and just [ __ ] give it your all and
give it your all and give it your all
and give it your all
and dude you could you go sledding go
[ __ ] sledding go sledding down a
[ __ ] snowy hill
and give it your all don't be a little
bitch-ass [ __ ] with a sled is
this how i
is this how i go head first into the
[ __ ] and if you hit a tree
life [ __ ] rips dude life rips
dude i had a paraplegic guy [ __ ]
write me recently and he told me life
rips
and i needed to hear that [ __ ] he told
me [ __ ] life rips
me his story and he told me life rips
and i believe him now
how about that give it your all because
you can
i'm tied for the number one dad
i watch this [ __ ] show on goddamn
hulu it's called kings of pain
and at first i'm like what is this show
and they explain for science they're
gonna go out
and they're gonna get bitten by
everything poisonous and they're gonna
rank it
and i go why
and they reply science now
is it [ __ ] or not is it just schlock
tv
i don't know but when i start watching
these [ __ ] are all in
you think they're stopping at bumblebees
dude
uh-uh they don't stop at bumblebees they
go to [ __ ]
what the f the tarantula hawk wasps or
whatever by the way that's some bit [ __ ]
if you're an animal named
uh by another animal like that would
make me so mad
if i was a [ __ ] lionfish you know
what i'm talking about
because you can't do anything about it
because you're a fish and you can't even
talk and even if it could be
you're underwater anyway but i would be
like don't call me another animal
have me be a spiky fish i gotta be a
[ __ ] another more ferocious animal
[ __ ] all that i'm a spike fish you know
what i'm talking about
it's bit [ __ ] but my point is
they didn't stop at bumblebee they went
to [ __ ]
that big ass wasp i think it's called
like the
whatever it is dude it's like that big
it's as big as a [ __ ] car key and
they and they
they boom they don't stop at that they
go to lionfish
boom the guy goes he touch he hits the
[ __ ] top of the lionfish with the
boom boom it hurts didn't stop there
went to the [ __ ]
fire ants or the harvest ants and did he
[ __ ] do one
oh let's get the forest let's get the
harvest and
let's put it on there boom no they
didn't do that they put a [ __ ]
bucket full of fire ants harvest ants
and the guy said i'm gonna stick my hand
in there
and i'm gonna [ __ ] keep it in there
for as long as i can
he gave it his all so i'm watching the
show and i'm like all right you know
what
i'm gonna watch the whole [ __ ] thing
dude i'm gonna watch the whole
thing because these guys gave it their
[ __ ] all and i'm like i watched six
episodes last night and i'm not stopping
dude
you give me your all i'll give you all
i'll watch the whole [ __ ] thing
this is real life [ __ ] dude these guys
oh you thought they stopped at harvest
ants
dude they do snakes you thought they
stopped at snakes
they do [ __ ] komodo dragons dude
this is a real [ __ ] thing i'm telling
you they go and they get a komodo dragon
and they stick their arm out and the
guy's like fire away
and the komodo dragon just goes chomp
and the guy goes oh it hurts
oh no [ __ ] dude and it's
dude you know the chomping power that a
[ __ ] komodo dragon has
you know what it is a lot and this dude
the dude the komodo dragon dude [ __ ]
chomped on his arm
and didn't for dude
for 11 minutes
11 [ __ ] minutes
and the guy's standing there with a
komodo dragon on his arm for 11 [ __ ]
minutes
this thing's a beast dude they grow to
be seven feet
that's as tall as shack
it's like the [ __ ] yummy of the
animal kingdom on this guy's
arm and just chilling arms down
it doesn't it doesn't need anything else
it's it's holding on to his forearm
arms down
like an archangel that took flight just
chilling just
hold and the guys oh it hurts
how do we get it off
the guys no it waits they waited till
everybody died and then the [ __ ]
komodo dragon died
and they stopped filming no but then
they ranked the [ __ ] pain
there was a dent in the [ __ ] guy's
arm there was a dent in the guy's arm
they went all in so that's what my
[ __ ] point is
go all in dude that's why i don't play
video games
i can't go all in i dick around i put
okay i'm done dude
but i did i tell you what man when all
this [ __ ] went down
when i had nothing to do um
kristen and i were like let's get video
games so we we did
well i was like i never really like
video games but let's try and play video
games
we got this game
that we both agreed on we can't agree on
a video game because i want to play the
ones where you [ __ ] shoot people's
faces off and she wants to play the ones
that are about like flowers jumping on
top of buildings or some [ __ ]
no let's play plants versus zombies and
i'm like oh for [ __ ] sake you know
and um so we got the uh
this game we finally figured out a game
that we agreed on because we googled
them all and it was this game called a
way out
and it's a game where you're in jail
and you have to help each other break
out and then help each other find the
guy that
put you there and
then at the end of the game spoiler
alert well before i even get to the
spoiler alert
it's a [ __ ] cool game it's it's kind
of like one of those games that i don't
like because you really just have to hit
the button when they say hit the button
it's like that's why i don't like guitar
hero because it's you just
you're not you're not shredding you know
and people are like
it's like you're just hitting the
buttons when you see hit the button
thing
like the games like street fighter
aren't like that you do the [ __ ]
you hit whatever you want to hit
whenever you want to hit it
call of duty you shoot whoever you want
you go around wherever you want to
but this game was like it was like oh
[ __ ]
remove the crate from the from the door
and you got to walk up and it says hit x
and you're just like
and the guy's like oh it's kind of heavy
you know
great walk through the door hit l to
unlock door and you're just like
and just because the graphics are so
good and the guy's nose looks real
you're like whoa
you know um
but i'm just like you're just hitting
but this people are telling me to hit
[ __ ] buttons and i'm just doing it
like a [ __ ] lab rat you know
anyway it was fun though to play it with
her because it was like a bonding thing
through this really emotional time in
our lives
and we thought it was just going to be
like a run and gunnam [ __ ] help each
other out
hey [ __ ] you drive i'll shoot the
guys behind us kind of game
you know and those parts were
very far few and far in between
but it was like we started getting
invested in the storyline and [ __ ] we
were like oh that's who did it okay cool
well you go into that house while i talk
to his wife and see what the [ __ ]
see what happened and then it would
split screen and like i'd be like
kind of sneaking my eyes over at her
thing but really i'd be like [ __ ]
doing my business and
like moving clothes over so i can get
some documents
ah what move close box
hit box
retrieve back document r2
and i'm just like you talking to his
wife she's like shh
i have to read the subtitles
and i'm like i got the documents i'll
just chill i'll meet you back near the
motorcycle
and then so we're like invested not only
in the game but like we're with each
other on the couch
and we're forgetting all of the [ __ ]
pain not all of it because it's right
there and it was hard you know to deal
with and it is hard to deal with but
we're we've got something
that we're focusing on instead of
you know and at the end of the game
spoiler alert
you find out
that you have to
[Music]
kill each other
and we've played this whole game
bonding and becoming closer as the
characters
and as the people on the couch that we
are
and now it's like
kill each other hit x
and i'm like dude and i look at her and
she's like
wha what and i'm like
we have to we have to kill each other
and she says
with the straightest face and i'm not
lying to you
i'm not trying to make this funny but
tears well up in her eyes
and she looks at me not the character
looking at the character
she looks at me on the couch and she
says
i can't do it and i say
it's just a game and the tears fall down
her cheeks
not lying for humor this is true and she
says
i'm not gonna [ __ ] kill you and i'm
like well
just no now i'm trying to make her feel
better
about this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass game
and i'm like why don't you just how
about this
you take the contr you just put
just take the controller i'll put it
down
and you just you kill me it's fine and
she's like i can't [ __ ] kill you i
don't even care if it's just a video
game
it doesn't matter i'm not going to kill
you in video games just like i want to
kill you in real life
crying hard even the dogs are like what
the [ __ ] is she doing
and i'm talking about like and obviously
we're cr she's
crying a lot and i'm i was even starting
to tear up because she was crying but
obviously we had our own [ __ ] going on
at that moment it was six months ago
but i didn't know what the solution was
because i'm like well i'm not gonna
[ __ ] kill you if you're not even
gonna she put the [ __ ] through the
controller down
i'm like it's just like shooting
somebody with no gun it's like
in the wild west it's like that's not
there's no respect in that
so i'm sitting there with x and i'm like
do i have to
i can't do it pick up your controller
and she goes i'm not doing it i knew she
wasn't gonna do it
so i [ __ ] grabbed her controller and
i
[ __ ] killed my character
and then we both [ __ ] and we both
[ __ ] cried together
because of [ __ ] goddamn
workers at capcom you know what i mean
or whatever it is
these [ __ ] [ __ ] workers at capcom
that are just like
[Music]
putting circuits in the [ __ ] yeah
some guy with like well you know it's
it's actually
it's much more realistic if the shadows
on the left you know because the light
source is coming from the other side
these [ __ ] guys would just so
you know i'm just saying we could have
the shadow at where it was
but it makes me laugh because it's
completely [ __ ] up
and and i'm [ __ ] we're sitting here
holding each other crying because i took
her [ __ ] controller and i killed
myself on the [ __ ] thing that they
create and they don't even know about it
maybe now they do this podcast is pretty
big
um anyway yeah
so we were all in on that game oh i was
talking about shaq dude
it's just yeah i i don't even know if i
had more to say about that but
i don't how long have i been going by
the way how long has it been
52. that we said wow
has it been good i don't even know
okay all right um i don't know anymore
i don't know anymore i don't know what's
good or what's bad i i don't even know
if i'll ever [ __ ] do stand up again
i'll tell you what when i go [ __ ] do
stand up
i i uh i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
bomb
and i hope i [ __ ] bomb i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i tried to make your [ __ ] laugh
for too long i'm just gonna go on stage
and i'm gonna [ __ ] dab bomb dude
i will bomb after a guy that kills i
don't care
i don't care i'll go on after the
[ __ ] killer and i'll go on and i'll
do a monologue
like it's in goddamn romeo and juliet i
don't care there won't be laughs
come see me let's all [ __ ] talk let's
all [ __ ] cry i don't give a [ __ ]
um
you rock with me you rock with me with
it with it all dude you rock with
all of it cause i'm
i'm all in because you got it you got to
be dude
like those [ __ ] who did the
stamping for the [ __ ] carmine jordans
dude
stampede they [ __ ] those guys who
want the shoes they [ __ ] run in they
run the [ __ ] in
they run in they move they're when when
my son
sees something he wants in in a in a
in a a at a in
in the house or whatever boom he sees it
[Laughter]
he's crawling it's like move other [ __ ]
moving it's just
shoelaces and [ __ ] gumballs just
moving moving them
it's like [ __ ] until he gets that
[ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] you gotta get back to
dude you let life
[ __ ] it up for you you second guess and
you
and you uh you don't pay attention to
your instincts
man and you become this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] of like uh
what society has made you you know i
don't i don't i hate even
saying society is so annoying at this
point
but like you gotta get to the point
where you're just
that [ __ ] kid getting that shoelace
do you know what i'm talking about
you're just that 13 month
old with your eyes on [ __ ] daddy's
shoelace
over in the corner it's not a toy you
don't give a [ __ ] that's what you want
you move your toys and you get that [ __ ]
it's a shame it's impossible to be that
way it really is
as a [ __ ] 30 40 50 year old it's
impossible to be that way
because you have uh you know you live
for other people
but you got to find the mix at least
that's what those guys are doing when
they're letting the [ __ ] wasps sting
them man
they're zoning in on that shoelace do
you understand what i'm saying
uh either be like that or be
shack and just be like i don't give a
[ __ ] i'll just hawk everything i have
four he's got 400 million dollars he's
still talking to a [ __ ] cartoon with
a big mustache on [ __ ] generals auto
assurance
um
so i think i'm done with the pens i
don't know
it would be fun i should wear them out
one but i should wear them on
i should wear them out to see if they
worked with just like a little bit of
piss
just with my skinny jeans but really
puffy in the [ __ ]
on my front like i'm [ __ ] winnie the
pooh
just [ __ ] fat a fat you know
like i got a fat
piece of [ __ ] gut um
one time when i was in uh college
i went to nyu for a year until i
realized that [ __ ] blue blue
blue [ __ ] blue [ __ ] i didn't like it i
don't like i didn't like college i hated
school dude i [ __ ] hated school
and uh you don't need to do school you
know
you need to do like up to like seventh
grade
and then it's like i gotta do
what equation uh you're like you're
[ __ ] 16 and you're like
i i i i gotta do i i i'm sorry i gotta
do
i gotta read their eyes were watching
god by
zora neale hurston why
because of what oh cause i'm gonna
forget it in [ __ ] four months
why what's it gonna tell me all right
i'm not even mature enough to know about
the [ __ ] life
about what it means
and uh
and so uh i hated school man
you got to do it up until like seventh
grade my son when he grows up and he
gets to eighth grade he's like dad i
don't want to do it anymore i go like
this
don't do it don't do it but figure out
what the [ __ ] you're gonna do in life
because i would have been a [ __ ]
comedian from jump dude
i would have been a comedian from gem i
was i'm just sitting in [ __ ] math
class
trying to make dumb jokes and getting
grounded for it this is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i made money on this is my career
i'd be in my parents bedroom late at
night trying to make them laugh and
they'd be like go to [ __ ] bed
this is the [ __ ] that i [ __ ] now i
made a living off of it
um but my point is
i hated school and i went to nyu
to appease my parents because i thought
you know what i should [ __ ] give it a
shot
and i did and i went and i just like
it was ending the year was ending and i
knew i wasn't going to go back
and my roommate
actually i shouldn't say his name
because i don't want to [ __ ] i don't
even know if he's alive
even at this point but he was a guy who
i realized like 12 years later
would tell me all the time about [ __ ]
osama bin laden and how good he was uh
i went to college
before 9 11. okay so this is why
the name osama bin laden didn't ring any
bells
but this kid who was from i don't know
some other country i don't even remember
at this point
but would tell me multiple times during
the year
about osama bin laden
and how good he was
and i would just be like yeah some have
been [ __ ] okay i don't know this
[ __ ] guy all right whatever but i
forgot about it
until i remembered it like 12 years
later and i was like this [ __ ]
my roommate was like worshiping osama
bin laden that's the [ __ ] who
did
oh i'll be [ __ ] damned didn't know
and i remember
he would just had this attitude of
you're a f you're a stupid [ __ ] guy
you know to me like i got a room with
you
he would laugh at my jokes sometimes but
you're a [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] guy is how he
would like
talk to me like no matter what he was
saying it was
you're a stupid [ __ ] guy like he
would be like are you going out tonight
and i would be like maybe i might go out
with my friends from tisch
and instead of the actual feeling of
the question are you going out tonight
he would be saying
you're a stupid you're a stupid [ __ ]
guy you know
and i would answer it and i would be mad
because i know he was thinking you're a
stupid [ __ ] guy
and
i would still try to make him laugh
though because i was like i'm gonna make
him laugh
and i'm gonna make him laugh because he
[ __ ] doesn't like me
and if i can make him laugh then i'm
good at making people laugh
and one time i was
he was trying to go to bed and i was
keeping him up because i wanted to make
him laugh
and i did a joke where i was singing
that started singing that song that silk
song
where it was [ __ ] you know that song
i
could play it man i don't i don't use
this [ __ ] sound board when i'm going
to start using the sound
board anymore but the i'll just play it
it's not like uh
lick you this is the [ __ ] i can only
play for like a few seconds right
the matter of this song freak me
[Music]
okay and in this song it goes
let me lick you up and down
[Laughter]
dude let me lick you up pen down
and i and i sang and i was doing a joke
where i sang the song and he was like oh
chris shut up
shut up chris shut up he was saying it
for like 10 minutes
and i was like let me lick you up and
down
until you say stop and he just goes
stop and i [ __ ]
fell out dude i was already laying down
because i didn't fall so i didn't fall
down but dude
he just in his accent wherever he was
from me just says stop
and i laughed until sunrise
do it it was so it was one of those
moments that just hit you
it was one of those moments honestly
that just gets you here it gets you
right here
it was like eating a1 and just [ __ ]
it gets your hair get you right here
um dude it was so [ __ ] funny and i
laughed so hard and then he started
laughing and we became friends for
[ __ ] five minutes dude
and then his president blew up the
[ __ ] world trade center so
yeah and then the president of his town
osama bin laden
blew up the [ __ ] world trade center
so
thanks a lot thanks a lot man but we
enjoyed those five minutes it's about
finding common ground
you know it's about finding common
[ __ ] ground
even with the guy who worships the guy
who's the president
of the [ __ ] world trade center
bombing
that moment let me lick you up and down
until you say stop stop and i [ __ ]
ah and he oh ho ho ho
on the 14th floor of union hall and
[ __ ] nyu
wow dude
almost 4 000 people died on that [ __ ]
day
um so anyway dude that's it
i'm done i [ __ ] and let me tell you
something man this podcast
i got you know this is this was actually
i didn't know it was
funny but it got a little bit real too
and like it's just i don't know some of
the episodes are gonna be like that
um and uh what's that say wazen
no what's this say
wait wazon wazin [ __ ] write better
it looks like a ransom note she's trying
to remind me of a [ __ ] story it says
matt wazen
i don't even know what the [ __ ] that
means
just like say it
yeah i know oh when it happened oh
just jesus christ okay
matt she says matt was in new york city
when 9 11 happened
oh yeah hey guys matt was
my brother matt was in it anyway my
brother matt was in nor
it was in new york city when 9 11
happened isn't that [ __ ]
great not great for this podcast
no he does have a cool story about it
but i'll let him tell it on his podcast
um so anyway
um that's it so look
sign sign up for we got the patreon it's
live
it's patreon.com crystalia
you can go sign up support your boy
uh and you can check out all the
different [ __ ] on there
and you can sign up for whatever you
want to i appreciate you dude
uh listening and i appreciate the
support
if you want to sign up for the patreon
great if you don't [ __ ]
don't uh
i love you guys man uh thanks for
listening
bye-bye
[Music]
you